what may look like a pile of rubbish to
the rest of us is a treasure trove for
Katya Varna she transforms discarded
bicycle tubing into something new and
exciting it's really a great material
it's water-resistant its airtight its
durable and can still be used for so
many different things it would be a
shame just to burn it Katja gives new
life to junk that would otherwise go up
in smoke in scrap yards like an iPad
case or a handbag all Koch's products
are handmade at her shop in Berlin she
gets the inner tubing also for
motorbikes and trucks and tire and bike
shops size shape and texture dictate its
eventual use it's often hard to tell
where the creative process will lead me
first I have to get a feel for the
material I may start with a rough idea
but that often gets discarded when
something more exciting occurs to me and
I end up with an entirely different
product Koch has been working with
rubber tubing now for six years she
first trained as a graphic designer
so she had to learn these techniques
luckily her material was never out of
reach I ride bikes and motorbikes so I'm
familiar with rubber tubing I started
experimenting with the material and
thought wow you can make practical
everyday objects out of it as well as
seals and patches my first product was a
keyring filled with air so if your keys
fell into water they wouldn't sink
and many products have followed how
about a case for glasses made from
motorbike tires under her KWD label
kochia also offers all kinds of
different bags from purses to large hand
bags the unique designs are customized
with tire treads patches valves and even
reflectors you sometimes get a few snide
remarks making money from trash but some
say what a brilliant idea what surprises
me is that it's usually older people who
are most impressed there's somebody
who's making something useful out of
that material that's great the designer
sells her accessories from her Berlin
shop and all across the world over the
Internet small bags cost between 20 and
35 euros belt bags are also on offer
it's a perfect fit
Koch's bags are evidence of an upcycling
trend transforming used objects back
into something valuable as a designer I
have responsibilities and I'm an
environmentally conscious person but
that's not the driving factor what
drives me first and foremost as a
designer is the encounter with and
transformation of the material and it
keeps on inspiring new objects whether
it's furniture or everyday objects like
a fruit bowl
this summer kochia is taking part in her
first joint exhibition in Berlin she'll
be showing some very different creations
made out of rubbish
Pecha finds inspiration when she's out
riding her bicycle I get lots of ideas
out on my bike it's important to look
around you at everything in the world
critically and that inspires new
projects catchy burner is not trying to
reinvent the wheel but whenever she
takes one apart she makes something new